[Musique]
on va gagner cette bataille comté par
comté région par région
tous ensemble les québécoises et les
québécois veut exige du changement cette
année à la can on est là pour faire plus
pour faire mieux pour tous les québécois
ont trait parce qu'on passe de ce combat
c'est ce qu'est le québec mérite ce quia
bonjour nous sommes à 100 jours à peu
près du scrutin qu'est ce qui vous
motive qu'est ce qui vous fait avancer
dans quel état d'esprit vous commencez
cette bataille je suis dans l'état
d'esprit de progrès importants accomplis
pour le québec au cours des dernières
années
une envie de continuer d'aller encore
plus loin pour les québécois et leur
qualité de vie pour notre économie et
c'est l'état d'esprit dans lequel je
suis actuellement un discours positif
une attitude positive également les
optimistes pour le québec est ce que
vous vous oubliez toutes les analyses
tout ce que d'abord vous oubliez les
sondages j'ai jamais porté beaucoup
d'attention les libyens sur mon époque
pas beaucoup d'attention j'ai jamais
moduler mais politique ou mes
convictions selon les sondages jamais
mais se battre les ventes un peu se
racontent des vents de changement c'est
plus compliqué que se bat contre un
adversaire ses savates définir le défi
c'est de montrer d'avoir eu avec
beaucoup changé depuis 2014 beaucoup
beaucoup et ensuite on voit un car nous
aussi le changement le renouveau dans
l'équipe considérable ces deux éléments
devant on a prouvé qu'on est capable de
changer le québec de transformer même il
faut aller encore plus loin qu'on a
l'équipe pour le faire pour monter dans
le ring prêt convaincant
vous devez j'imagine être convaincu que
si jouables dont il apparaît difficile
jouanno ce bouddha profondément le soir
embauché comme par la malchance vous
êtes garde on est capable d'aller
chercher croyez on va l'avoir
et j'en suis convaincu quand j'ai
commencé la campagne en 2004 on avait
neuf points de retard et on appuie sur
plein de nombreuses reprises je suis pas
que les sondages sont pas fiables et se
baser là dessus pour développer son
attitude par rapport à une campagne
les idées comme un maître dans la
population c'est vraiment pas une bonne
idée j'avais besoin d'y croire pour vrai
oui dans sa satire est pourquoi on est
en politique sont pour quelque chose
moi je crois fondamentalement à
l'importance du pôle au québec d'avoir
une économie en croissance qui
s'ajustent au changement profond du
monde qui nous entoure aux nouvelles
technologies à la société qui change
mais j'y crois beaucoup à ça est ce que
ça vous atteint le ton jusqu'ici on sait
à quel point sur les réseaux sociaux la
marque libérale c'est dur on entend lis
des choses hargneux est ce que ça vient
vous chercher les pauses on me pose
c'est une perte de temps une perte
d'énergie puisque ça fait sa grande
mauvaise humeur et moi je vais être de
bonne humeur
alors non je regarde les analyses
d'opinion par exemple de plusieurs
personnes dont je respecte beaucoup des
opinions dans les médias mais sinon
pollini les commentaires en bas des
articles ni les médiations mais ça ça
crée une atmosphère quand même est ce
que oui parce qu'il ya des collègues qui
vous disent on trouve ça dur et on se
fait dire sur ce roi la politique c'est
dur pour tout le monde
la politique c'est on est rendu à
l'époque de l'union courte qui ne peut
être que plus de quelques secondes ou
une coupe de minutes
on est rendu au point des opinions
extrêmes le trancher la violence même
verbale parfois si c'est ça mais je peux
pas moins me laisser envahir par ça je
peux pas me laisser contaminer par sa
jeune encore une fois concentré sur ce
qu'on a accompli et ce qu'on doit
accomplir pour la suite des choses
est-ce que vous avez des craintes
quelles seraient vos craintes avant
d'entreprendre la bataille qu'est ce
qu'elle est l'aspect que vous trouvez
vous le plus difficile à ce qui va
arriver dans le sens proche donc d'abord
à court terme je pense que de plus en
plus le message parce que les choses
vont bien au québec on a transformé le
québec pour le mieux une époque tout
soit parfait entendons nous mais les
choses sont pour le mieux ça c'est la
première chose il faut s'asseoir
là-dessus mais ensuite porté le projet
plus loin et voient la crédibilité de le
porter plus loin parce qu'on a accompli
mais également par l'équipe qui nous
entoure parce que vous dites le
changement tout le monde a peur du
changement mais le tiff changement
pourquoi et changement pour qui voilà la
question qui si pertinente
parlez-moi de vos adversaires une
seconde qui a égalé le temps que vous
souhaiter pour cette campagne d'entre
vous entre les quatre chefs de moi j'ai
décidé que je ferai
très très peu d'interventions ou pas
d'intervention au niveau personnel sur
les collègues les chefs de partis je
pourrais bien sûr critiquer des idées ou
des propositions ou demander des
précisions
mais j'ai pas l'intention de descendre
dans ce niveau de débat la discussion là
la politique ça devient facilement
personnaliser et je trouve moi je veux
pas ça je crois que mes collègues n'ont
plus j'espère y coller nos très bien
fait de couleurs après la pause on va
parler justement des sujets importants
quelques prêts publics occupent les
québécois la santé les vocations sont
dans deux minutes et demie allons-y
[Musique]
notre parti formera à nouveau le
gouvernement des québécois et ce sera un
gouvernement majoritaire
enfin prenez miner son viennent vous
entendre devant vos militants et
certains chaabi demandé fois qu'est ce
qui le motive at-il encore le goût dont
l'objet était de bonne humeur
non je vous avais encore totalement le
goût pour non pas pour être en politique
ou faire la télévision les entrevues ou
ou avoir sa photo sur des affiches mais
pour accomplir quelque chose pour le
québec et les québécois on est déjà
accompli beaucoup depuis 2014 et aucun
doute qu'on a accompli beaucoup de
choses et je pense qu'on a une
perspective d'aller encore plus loin
pour les québécois et c'est ce qui
motive tous les jours
éducation peut-être que cette fois ci on
va réussir en parler davantage parce
qu'on dit souvent qu'on veut en parler
ça devient le 8ème sujet or c'est
important c'est fondamental c'est un
pilier pour notre société ça il ya eu
des moments des années difficiles qui
soit le pendant deux ans un
ralentissement de la croissance des
budgets et non pas un recul des budgets
toujours pas de regret pour l'éducation
non parce que si on n'avait pas fait ça
on n'aurait pas les marges de manoeuvre
qu'on a maintenant pour financer non
seulement en général les services une
politique de réussite éducative une
approche pour les tout petits de 0 à 8
ans des nouvelles écoles modernes avec
la bricole on a plein de ressources
maintenant pour aller encore plus loin
que je se mettent de l'argent dans le
système public il faut aller au delà de
ça il faut penser aux façons de faire
maternelle 4 ans vous voyez la cac qui
promet pour tous les enfants du québec
vous vous dites utilement ce serait une
bonne idée mais c'est irréaliste le
premier au monde
oui ça prend 2006 en classe de 1600 pour
un professeur 2,6 2,7 milliards
d'investissement
ça va se réaliser mais c'est impossible
de faire son en un an deux ans ou même
trois ans doit se faire progressivement
il manque de locaux il manque
d'enseignants on est déjà prévu
d'engager presque plus de sept mille
enseignants cours des prochaines années
et non pas d'engager d'autres en plus
cela il faut se poser des questions
quand quant à la main d'oeuvre
disponible quant aux locaux disposent de
bonnes idées mais entre-temps pourquoi
ne pas utiliser notre réseau de services
de garde éducatifs pour les enfants de 4
ans qui sont dans les services de garde
ne soient pas désavantagées soit tout de
suite dans un environnement éducatif
tout le monde s'entend qui font
intervenir plus tôt qu'est-ce que vous
quelle est votre idée maîtresse en
éducation justement comment résumer ce
que le message ou les fera passer au
québec - propos de l'éducation là parce
que alors l'intervention précoce dès le
jeune âge également les habitudes des
églises habiletés fondamentales savoir
lire écrire compter le plus tôt possible
dans la vie il reste après suis une
attitude générale envers l'éducation de
la société qui positive qui voient ça
comme véritablement la priorité de notre
société ça passe par les familles
également mais si je réussis je répète
le fondamental avant d'aller noël le
numérique et les appareils les ipad et
les ordinateurs dans un environnement
éducatif le plus tôt possible pour
dépister des problèmes habitabilité de
lecture et de numératie le plus tôt
possible que dès que les jeunes garçons
et encore un retard énorme son compteur
avec l'interview que je peux entrer dans
le débat
entendons nous c'était peut-être pas
tout à fait adéquat de comparer
directement les deux systèmes mais il ya
clairement mieux à faire au québec en
termes de diplomation ayant leurs tâches
et les garçons et qu'est ce qu'on voit
qui marche actuellement chez nous mais
d'abord les sports le sport études ça
marche pour les gars deuxièmement j'ai
vu à la polyvalente à l'école secondaire
vanier la robotique enseigner aux jeunes
il fait aussi s'y intéressent mais des
garçons sont passionnés faire des petits
robots les programmes et là il trouve
une raison d'être à l'école qui les
passionne faut garder les gars sont
actifs notamment avec les sports mais
intéressé dans les sujets nouveau et je
pense qu'on va y arriver très bien il
faut suivre ce qui se fait de mieux chez
nous sa vie se fait plein de belles
choses quelqu'un disait c'est très joli
comme formule l'école idéale elle existe
au québec mais par morceau un peu
partout lorsqu'il faudrait si de face et
la ramener un peu ce qu'on veut faire
avec l'elam école santé l'homme ce coup
là ça fait quatre ans que sont d'abord
le salaire des médecins
on dirait que vous payez un gros prix
politique pour un rattrapage de dépasser
le rattrapage est ce que l'or vous avez
pas grandi en a trop fait leur a fallu
stopper la machine n'est pas arrivé si
on arrêtait complètement de mettre de
l'argent neuf pour les médecins
spécialistes en 2014 les seuls médecins
qui a eu de l'argent neuf après 2014 sur
son les omnipraticiens les médecins de
famille pour diminuer l'écart entre eux
et les médecins spécialistes
des gens reconnaissent qu'il fallait
agir de ce côté là on a eu des gains
importants en matière de service celui
récemment on a annoncé que les blocs
opératoires des régions seraient
couverts pendant tout l'été ben c'est un
des effets de cette entente également de
diminuer le poids de la rémunération des
médecins dans le système de santé parce
qu'on pouvait pas continuer comme ça on
est très en train d'augmenter
continuellement le poids de la
rémunération médical système de santé
dont le stabiliser il va diminuer au
tour de l'ain pour cent ce qui nous
permet d'aider les infirmières à avoir
de meilleures conditions de travail de
développer des soins partout partout
dans les régions dites mais quand on se
compare à l'ontario ont parlé
l'éducation en seconde on voit que les
médias - père capita de médecins non
thériault mais il travaille davantage de
ce que - datant ça il n'y a pas des
médecins qui sont morts de rire je
deviens des métis pas tous les noms des
examens qui font moins d'heures compte
tenu de leurs revenus qui est tout le
monde moi je connais beaucoup de
médecins québécois puis je pense que
j'en étais qui travaille beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup
il faut se garder de généraliser les
choses la suppression gamme généralement
par là il ya quelque chose qui est
évident pour tous les québécois
on a un nombre plus élevé de médecins
par habitant que d'autres provinces
canadiennes et jusqu'à récemment mais on
fait des progrès on avait moins d'accès
par exemple aux médecins de famille qui
marchent pas là on en a c'est donc pour
le faire et je pense c'est pour ça que
gaétan barrette à l'ue a adopté cette
loi pour amener les médecins à prendre
des patients dans leur clientèle à les
suivre et on fait des progrès quand même
plus d'un million de personnes de plus
qui ont un médecin de famille mais ça
tombe bien vous dit docteur barrette
il avait la carotte et le bâton que vous
lui affirme année en lui le bâton avec
les médecins c'est plus lui qui a
négocié et lui c'est un secret de
polichinelle qui pensent qu'on a
peut-être donné un peu trop parce que
lui voulait exigé justement des
rendements et ce qui faisait pas la
sphère des fédérations de médecins
bref comme premier ministre est-ce que
vous avez pas tranché trop en faveur des
médecins savez on a encore les lois
fondamentales que gaétan barrette a fait
adopter elles sont encore là et on était
très clair avec les médecins vous avez
les objectifs par exemple le pourcentage
de personnes qui ont des médecins de
famille ont fait des progrès mais on
n'est pas vendu partout au québec un
objectif dans ma région saguenay lac
saint jean
on est au delà de l'objectif il ya des
régions comme montréal ou n'y est pas
alors il ya assez de médecins il ya
assez de ressources
prenez des patients fait du suivi et
sinon il ya des dispositions de la loi
c'est la loi 20
qui vont s'appliquer et même chose pour
les spécialistes ce que vous dites à vos
collègues chefs de partis qui disent
nouveau rouvrir cette entente là on va
les rechercher de l'argent des bonnes
chances et il pourrait nous expliquer où
vous expliquer comment ils vont faire ça
alors je vois la scène
un de mes collègues appelant le
président de la fédération des
spécialistes demain on renégocie c'est à
partir de zéro je suis pas sûr que ça va
être bien reçu ça se fera pas comme ça
oubliez pas qu on a récupéré plus de
trois milliards de dollars par rapport à
ce qui était dur de récupérer 3
milliards de dollars à ce que j'ai dit
partiellement mon collègue monsieur
lebon lorsqu'il a mentionné sa jeudi à
partir du moment où vous dites ça vous
mettez un risque plus de 3 milliards de
dollars de fonds publics va falloir que
votre cadre financier identifie ce
risque là après il y en a moins parlé
parce que c'est clair que c'est la
réalité transports on et puis c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour le québec on
s'éveille à des grands projets de bruit
un collectif mobilité durable mobilité
québec si montréal pardon est-ce que
comment on fait pour prioriser tous ces
projets ou est-ce que vous déjà vous
êtes rendu rives rem plus vrai sur le
nord montérégie avait bouffé disons à
long ou très rapidement à la retraite
à québec c'est le grand projet
structurant et le troisième est à
étudier également et à faire vous vous
dites a étudié à faire et à faire mais
il faut le faire correctement et
intelligemment la différence avec le
goût là tu sais quoi c'est que moi je
pense reprend des études sérieuses avant
de dire que ça me prend le temps
d'années que ça va coûter tant il faut y
joindre un élément de transport
collectif sinon ça n'a pas de sens on
peut me troisième bière ça c'est québec
tu es maintenant montréal vous avez la
ligne bleue vers m avec la rive sud de
l'aéroport
et maintenant c'est la couronne de
montréal ce avec un enjeu majeur de
mobilité de congestion à couronne nord
les basses laurentides laval et pour ça
il faut faire plusieurs choses pas juste
une chose moi j'ai parlé de prolonger
une antenne du rem jusqu'à mirabel ce
serait déjà un très bon départ lui il
faut également des réseaux d'autobus
avec des voies réservées pour que les
gens délaissent la voiture individuelle
le plus possible ils vont le faire voici
on les force à le faire car si on leur
offre quelques uns quand les gens
peuvent voir sur la rive nord
l'autre jour j'étais à laval puis j'ai
pris un autobus intelligent je crois que
c'est sur le boulevard curé labelle 7
octobre et cela des censeurs qui
avertissent les feux de circulation du
nombre de personnes dans l'autobus et
également du temps accumuler de retard
et à ce moment là les feux de
circulation s'adapte tout seul je peux
vous dire qu'on avait beaucoup plus vite
que les autos à côté alors si on offre
aux gens des solutions
abordable et confortables ils vont
choisir m plus au nord bien même plus en
montérégie
quand il faut d'abord dans le cas du
rêve
vous avez tous comptables c'est de ce
nom sont passés les milliards de dollars
déjà les projets qu'on a annoncé c'est
14 milliards
chaque fois vous en ajoutez 1 c'est
quelques milliards depuis six ans ghana
qu'il faut dire non quand par exemple
gatineau ouest moi je suis d'accord avec
outaouais il faut améliorer le rapibus
qui fait du nord sud est de faire
connecter l'autre côté de l'outaouais le
train léger et une excellente idée mais
ce qu'on va faire
parce qu'on peut pas exiger de la caisse
des dépôts qu'elles le fassent s'il a
demandé d'examiner ces projets là s'ils
sont compatibles avec leurs priorités et
leurs politiques parce que sinon il n'y
a pas de place pour la dette du québec
de faire tout ça très rapidement mais on
peut le faire si on fait un peu la même
chose qu'on a fait avec les rênes pour
dégager des sommes pour le reste de
l'immobilisation du gouvernement parce
que la tranquille à 55 ans 50 50 qu'il
faut terminer comme il faut l'a19 ça
c'est des engagements sa valise en gare
mais c'est déjà fait c'est déjà en cours
l'a19 ça y est c'est réglé halmos faire
là 30 il faut l'élargir sur une section
avec des voies réservées
d'ailleurs les voies réservées mon
arrivée avant l'élargissement mais en
montérégie c'est tellement vaste comme
région comment allons nous amener les
gens au métro il y aurait alors il faut
penser également système d'autobus était
du genre covoiturage derniers milles
comment on voit de l'arrêt d'autobus a
chez soi par exemple immigration à ce
que le débat c'est à votre avis apaisé
au québec
là j'espère j'espère parce que compte
tenu de la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
majeur convient vous savez que
maintenant on parlera plus beaucoup de
créer des emplois on va parler de
combler les emplois disponibles
alors continue ça on a absolument besoin
d'une immigration au québec
moi j'en parle maintenant en termes
économiques je veux pas qu'on ait encore
séduction se jugent les uns les autres
selon nos valeurs et selon qu'on est
ouvert ou moins ouverts je dis
simplement la chose suivante en période
de pénurie de main-d'oeuvre ça n'a pas
de sens de réduire l'émigration
économique vouloir réduire les seuils
comment vous qualifier sa baisse et
c'est prendre un risque avec l'économie
du québec cette année
juste cette année on aurait besoin de
100 mille personnes de plus ce marché du
travail et c'est des centaines de
veiller au cours des prochaines années
alors il faut toujours bien les intégrer
les franciser est grand temps pour les
garder parce que vous dites on bouge pas
le seuil sans grande peine mais il y en
avait à peu près 20 milles qui partent
quand même comment on fait pour les
gardes
vous avez remarqué également que le taux
de chômage
granby sont continuelles bonne nouvelle
le taux de participation au marché du
travail
les immigrés y au moins le même que des
québécois qui sont là depuis plus
longtemps
autre bonne nouvelle alors c'est pas
vrai qu'ils font qui sont là et qui sont
pas productifs ils veulent travailler
elles veulent travailler et on en a
besoin dans les régions également comme
moi le défi c'est pas uniquement des
années au québec mais également des
années dans les régions
il leur donner accès à l'emploi dans nos
régions comme la mienne dont elle a
désespérément besoin de m mais comment
faire pour mieux les intégrer pour
qu'ils apprennent davantage le français
pour que j'en ai moins qu'ils repartent
tout accord pour la francisation on a
ajouté beaucoup de somme on en est à 225
millions c'est quand même considérable
mais moi j'ai remarqué quelque chose par
mon expérience de région parce qu'on
voit les nouveaux arrivants qui arrivent
et ils s'intègrent les enfants là et
aucun problème de francisation et
apprennent la langue comme des éponges
littéralement ils sont à l'école c'est
pour les adultes c'est difficile et moi
je suis convaincu que ça va aller mieux
pour eux d'être transfusés en entreprise
et c'est déjà fait au québec
actuellement c'est la raison pour
laquelle lors du congrès on a pris
l'engagement d'augmenter les crédits
pour la francisation en entreprise pour
participer au marché du travail dès le
début du coup y'a comme un à un mot plus
qualifiés actuellement les relations
fédérales provinciales sont l'objet de
tensions sur certains sujets comme c'est
normal dans toutes les fédérations
mais sinon il ya énormément de
collaboration sur bien des enjeux
également par exemple les
infrastructures où on vient de
s'entendre avec le fédéral toujours il y
aura toujours des tensions
quelle que soit l'évolution de la
fédération il y aura toujours des
tensions entre deux ordres de
gouvernement puis mon rôle à moi c'est
de promouvoir les intérêts du québec
certainement très bien fait le bruit à
vous restez avec nous après la pose des
questions en rafale d'accord à tous
[Musique]
je couds ya quelques questions en rafale
est ce qu'il est possible de promettre
aux québécois un temps d'attendre
maximum aux urgences avant de voir un
médecin si oui combien de temps c'est
pas la bonne engagement à prendre pour
leur donner un autre endroit que
l'urgence pour aller se faire soigner
comme l'espère kilic donc pour les
urgences vont travailler sur un autre
option que l'urgence d'accord pour
donner de l'argent public un nouveau
stade de baseball à l'horaire pas d'abo
paul pourtant pas dans un premier temps
c'est au secteur privé de mettre
l'argent et si c'est payant impôts
secteur privé sous surveillance les
contribuables est-ce que ça a été est-ce
que construire le centre vidéotron avec
essentiellement que de l'argent public
itinera c'était bien d'avoir de
l'ambition on espère toujours moi
j'aimerais bien avoir une équipe de
ligue nationale à québec franchement
c'est un endroit idéal pour sa main dans
la main avec justin trudeau pour contrer
la guerre commerciale de monsieur tron
il faut tout le monde va s'unir je crois
que tout le monde l'a fait récemment à
travers les partis politiques province
territoire fédéral tout le monde est uni
etes-vous ouvert à des concessions dans
la gestion de la foi non non on a déjà
fait des concessions de fait deux
concessions déjà et les transformateurs
peu moins nos producteurs actuellement
je pense qu'on a assez donné
parité obligatoire dans un conseil de
ministres hautement souhaitable je pense
qu'elle va devenir obligatoire
socialement de toute façon moi c'est mon
objectif
salaire minimum 15 $ ou une quatrième
semaine de vacances salaire minimum à 50
% du salaire horaire moyen c'est ce que
les économistes nous recommande et on
vient de devancer la troisième semaine
de vacances plus tôt que ce qui est
prévu
est ce que le gouvernement du québec à
un contrôle sur les fluctuations du prix
de l'essence il ce qui peut ressembler
des fois à de la collusion très peu et
on peut par exemple analyser les
diverses composantes du prix on a très
peu de contrôles de contrôle direct la
meilleure option pour les québécois
c'est de poser le plus beau geste de
nationalisme économique et de choisir le
véhicule électrique maintenant au sujet
du véhicule électrique
l'ontario john 13000 qui évacue email
vous prêts remontent mais l'on va voir
parce que monsieur fraude mines se
retirer du marché du carbone qui était
le sources de fonds pour ça alors qu'est
ce qu'il va faire avec ça je lis
vraiment être bien c'est parce qu'on a
fait assez et surtout on restreint
maintenant aux véhicules de plus bas
prix allez-vous faire un test de goût
à la prochaine est ce que c'est vous
allez goûter les différents sortes de
pâtes
écoutez je n'ai jamais pris de ma vie
puis je me vante pas de ce pas ce que
j'aurais peut-être été plus jeunes qui
s'affrontent et peut-être ça mais non je
pense pas faire cette expérience là là
est ce que le québec
vous allez aimer celle là c'est la même
question à tous les chefs est-ce que ça
porte mieux aujourd'hui qu'il y a quatre
bien sûr c'est évident beaucoup mieux
finances publiques économie recul de la
pauvreté dans tous les secteurs
le québec est beaucoup mieux est ce qui
est parfait non mais il est beaucoup
mieux en 2014
et vous dites vous ne dirai jamais qu'on
l'a peut-être fait un peu trop vite cet
effort on doit peut-être demander trop à
certaines personnes mais je pense qu'il
fallait le faire parce que yo rien qui
criaient qui est possible de faire sans
les marges de manoeuvre il fallait
développer rapidement pour vous donner
encore plus de vigueur à nos
investissements dans les services
publics et dans l'économie mais pour
être honnête effectivement il ya deux
ans lors d'une entrevue on vous disait
impossible de sens et je voulais vous le
dire c'est vous qui veulent faire une
démonstration implacable
j'avais dit que y'a puis j'avais été un
peu dur à dre un peu et vous arriverez
on est à 2 130 à 200 en avance parce que
n'oubliez pas sur cinq ans donc mai 2010
9 en juin 2018 on est à 230 mille
chansons bas on va croiser les doigts et
vous savez la prochaine campagne
électorale
on dira pas on va créer ou faire créer
autant d'emplois on va dire voir combler
les emplois disponibles c'est ça le
revirement historique est devant nous à
tuer et c'est du jamais vu jamais vu
effectivement je suis québec je décide
ce chaînon particulièrement parce que
notre démographie déjà avec dvd
vulnérabilité très bien première
priorité
si vous êtes élue prononce remplir nos
engagements mais contre les premières
première priorité donner la gratuité des
services de garde à quatre ans comme on
a dit qu'on ferait
que faites vous pour vous évader ce que
vous priez est-ce que vous je lis
énormément et des sujets qui n'ont pas
grand chose à voir avec l'actualité
politique ou le moins possible les trucs
historique beaucoup tellement je suis un
peu passionné par l'époque médiévale
alors je m'informe là dessus puis mes
loisirs essentiellement c'est la pêche à
la mouche alors moi pour moi c'est ainsi
plus qu'un loisir c'est une passion il
était arrivé et je vais y aller même si
voir une campagne électorale je tiens si
on me prenait quelques quelques jours le
brouillard
bonne chance et girouard se croient les
13 septembre voilà merci beaucoup plus à
bientôt
[Musique]